c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
sont les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir les réactions au mali au
lendemain des sanctions de la cedeao les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement
d'afrique de l'ouest en classe et le
mali sous embargo pour sanctionner le
maintien de la junte au pouvoir la junte
qui dénonce des sanctions illégales et
illégitimes
nous écouterons amadou maïga premier
secrétaire parlementaire du cnt il était
avec nous tout à l'heure un bras de fer
entre la cedeao et le mani sur fond de
déploiement de mercenaires du groupe
bruce wagner leur nombre est estimé à
environ 400 selon certaines sources il
serait à près de 200 à ségou à 200 km au
nord au nord-est de bamako les matches
de la can la coupe d'afrique des nations
passera en revue à la fin de ce journal
les résultats des matches du jour le
maroc la guinée le sénégal et le gabon
ont réussi leur entrée dans la
compétition nous serons à dakar dans ce
journal
le gouvernement du mali condamne
énergiquement ces sanctions illégales et
illégitimes ce sont les mots du colonel
abdoulaye maïga porte parole du
gouvernement quelques heures après l
annonce des sanctions contre le mali par
la cedeao écoutez la réaction d'amadou
maïga premier secrétaire parlementaire
du cnt le conseil national de transition
il était avec nous tout à l'heure
je condamne arrête là j en tout cas
cette sanction une opportunité 10sport
disproportionnée de la hague la de la
cbao je pense qu'elle aurait pu s'en
passer de cette sanction et je ne
comprends pas du tout cette sanction
dans la mesure où moi j'étais du n 5 la
lutte est lui qui a conduit en tout cas
à la démission du président et son
excellence ibrahim boubacar kéita et
nous on est pas sorti non seulement que
pour l'organisation des élections mais
nous sommes sortis parce que le peuple
en a marre nous sommes sortis parce que
nous voulons une commission geri a
acceptables et acceptées de tous les
maliens et aujourd'hui l'âge est venu
nous voir parce que nous l'avons demandé
parce que nous l'avons voulue et 7e pour
nous la soutenons avec notre avec toute
l'énergie en tout cas qui nous anime est
aujourd'hui ils avaient dit qu'il y
avait des parquets skoda au cours de
leur sommet ils ont compris à travers
aujourd'hui que leur voix discordantes
il n'était juste qu'il est à paris il
avait dit quel cirque colonel ne voulait
pas quitter le pouvoir et aujourd'hui
ils ont compliqué sur le peuple qui
réclame en tout cas c'est un colonel au
pouvoir il avait dit aussi que nous
sommes incapables d'organiser des
élections mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui
avec tout ce qui se passe avec la
suspension du mot d'ordre des
enseignants signataires du 15 octobre
avec le la lettre de la plus grande
centrale syndicale je pense qu'ils ont
compris aujourd'hui que le peuple malien
aspire en tout cas un changement plus
profond regret à une information plus
provoc n'est-il pas possible d'organiser
des élections en moins de 6 ans
pas du tout moi je vous donne comme
exemple ça de l'assemblée nationale du
régime déchu je pense qu'en ce moment il
y avait non seulement la communauté
internationale il y avait la vidéo et
tout l'arsenal juridique qui accompagne
ce régime mais malgré tout ils n'ont pas
pu organiser les élections législatives
et ils ont prolongé de deux ans le
mandat des députés aujourd'hui la
situation sécuritaire s'est dégradée
pendant un certain temps et aujourd'hui
que nous demande organiser des élections
sachant très bien que ce n'est pas
possible et que les conditions ne sont
pas réunies et surtout que on n'organise
pas seulement que les élections
législatives ou présidentielles mais il
ya aussi des élections communales que
l'on doit organiser aujourd'hui c'est
qu'ils oublient de dire c'est que la
situation sécuritaire s'est nettement
améliorée aujourd'hui
du mali c'est aussi qu'il faut dire et
féliciter et dialoguer avec le
gouvernement actuel du mali pour pouvoir
bien entendu accepté en tout cas les
prises de deux sorties proposées par ce
gouvernement de la république sinon sans
quoi vouloir aller aux cinq sens je
pense que la sanction en tout cas
aujourd'hui à l'heure actuelle n'est pas
une semaine
justement quelles conséquences pourrait
avoir ses sanctions sur le pays
ces sanctions d'abord dans un premier
temps peut peut-être entraîné une
inflation à un certain niveau et une
raréfaction des dalles et de importés
mais rassurez vous aujourd'hui avec les
équipes techniques du ministère de
l'économie et des finances moi je suis
économiste nous avons tenu beaucoup de
réunions pour essayer de trouver des
recettes de titus eu en tout cas à ce
produit importé pour qui la prise ne
puisse pas à impacter à tout cas pour
que le choc puisse être à tenir
vis-à-vis de la population est
aujourd'hui encore nous avons aussi
réduit en tout cas les associations des
pâquis établissements financiers pour
pouvoir
et évaluer exactement les ressources qui
restent à l'état pour pouvoir
subvenir aux besoins de la population
j'attendais sur votre plateau quelqu'un
disait que
l'état peut résister pendant deux ans je
pense que c'est une erreur mais sa part
parce que seul le trésor public du mal
peut dire exactement quelle est en tout
cas la capacité des religieux de
résistance de notre de notre état
vis-à-vis du gel de ses avoirs en quoi
au niveau de l'apc et je pense qu'ils
seront surpris car nous avons déjà à
dissiper sur beaucoup d'aspects sur
beaucoup de plans ces sanctions qui en
tout cas en notre avis étaient quelques
pâles prévisible parce que les chefs
d'état de la cedeao les pays de la
cedeao sont à la solde d'une puissance
est le sol d'une puissance étrangère
alors laquelle justement parce que le
porte parole du gouvernement a déclaré
que la cedeao était une instance
régionale sous influence de puissances
extra régional quelles sont ces
puissances
n'ont pas ces puissances mais d'une
puissance parce que cette puissance
aujourd'hui c'est elle qui rendrait le
vendre aujourd'hui au monde entier à
l'arrivée
cette puissance qui a eu en tout cas
mais a donné la toute première
information de l'arrivée 2
à qui faites-vous allusion cette puce un
os je fais allusion à la france bien
évidemment j'ai fait allusion à la
france parce que c'est la france
aujourd'hui qui perd l'utility du
terrain au sein de la au sein de
l'afrique voire oubliée aujourd'hui le
mali en tout cas c'est là ce pays qui va
donner le ton pour que l'ingérence
française
cesse d'exister en tout cas dans notre
état est aujourd'hui le dijon et nous
incarnons à tout cas avec la plus grande
énergie cette défense de notre parti
vis-à-vis de l'ingérence étrangère
aujourd'hui le mali est un pays
souverain nous pouvons en tout cas
entamé un dialogue ou en tout cas des
partenariats qu'elle est temporaire avec
le nepad quel état pourvu que en tout
cas les populations se sentent bien et
pourvu que nous puissions souvenirs à
leurs besoins et surtout la sécuriser
sécuriser leurs moyens et les retenir
surtout vous l'avez entendu les
autorités maliennes ne reconnaissent pas
la présence des mercenaires wagner sur
leur territoire et pourtant de
nombreuses sources attestent de leur ans
dans le pays les détails avec monia
kacem
ce sont les toutes premières images de
la présence au mali des hommes du groupe
wagner des mercenaires russes en tenue
militaire ne portant aucun un signe
distinctif ce convoi de quelques hommes
se déplacent à bord de véhicules blindés
dans le centre du mali les photos ont
été prises à la fin du mois de décembre
dans la commune de ségou située à 200 km
au nord-est de la capitale bamako
aujourd'hui on sait qu'il y aurait donc
deux cents de ces hommes dans cette
région de ségou cm qu'il rayonne aurait
autour d'une zone 1 radiant autour de la
zone dont deux de ces gouttes qui serait
bien plus nombreux on parle de 400
personnes 400 à 450 personnes
aujourd'hui membre de la milice bien sûr
de wagner ce qu'ils y font quelle va
être la finalité les effectifs est ce
que c'est du contre terrorisme est ce
que c'est la garde présidentielle comme
c'est le cas en bandits dans le pays
d'afrique centrale on ne le sait pas une
présence désormais avéré pour une
mission qui reste inconnu à bamako les
autorités de transition n'ont pour le
moment admis que la présence
d'instructeurs russe en mission de
formation pourtant la déflagration d'une
mine le 3 janvier dernier au sud de
mopti a mis à mal la version officielle
une explosion suivie d'affrontements
entre russes et djihadistes plusieurs
sources affirment qu'un mercenaire russe
a été tué le déploiement des hommes de
wagner est surveillé de près par les
militaires français de l'opération
barkan sur le terrain la situation
pourrait devenir délicate si russes et
français venaient à se croiser pour le
moment les deux contingents sont
déployées dans des zones différentes
c'est la fin de la 83e semaine sans
école en ouganda la crise liée aux
crevettes 19 a eu raison de l'éducation
quelques 15 millions de jeunes landais
ont pu reprendre le chemin de l'école
avec la réouverture des établissements
scolaires fermés depuis presque deux ans
en raison de l'épidémie de kobe de 19
on en vient à la coupe d'afrique des
nations les lions de la teranga battu
les warriors du zimbabwe 1 but à 0 un
penalty à la dernière seconde de sadio
manet et pourtant l'équipe sénégalaise a
été diminuée par le cos vide les détails
avec notre correspondante à dakar
sarrassat coup
il n'y a pas eu de mobilisation
particulière pas d'engouement autour de
ce premier match des lions certains
dakarois à qui nous avons parlé nous ont
même avoué ne pas avoir suivi la partie
d'autres et ils sont nombreux estiment
que cette première prestation des lions
est assez raté alors bien sûr parmi les
supporteurs il y a ceux qui choisissent
de ne retenir que la victoire et ce
penalty tiré par sadio manet à la toute
dernière minute du match les autres sont
assez critiques envers la sélection
nationale je vous propose d'écouter ses
réactions ça va pas il n'y a pas de
collectif il ya aucun fond de jeu c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment déplorable
opération
massive
bonjour ils ont bien joué mais par
contre
les sénégalais ont désormais les yeux
rivés vers le derby de vendredi et ce
match sénégal guinée qui s'annonce comme
l'un des premiers chocs de cette can il
espère que l'équipe aura une meilleure
cohésion entrera plus de dynamisme et
surtout que certains joueurs absents
pour cause de covin notamment auront
retrouvé le terrain de football
après les lions de la teranga on vous
parle des lions de l'atlas l'équipe du
maroc a battu le ghana 1 but à 0 un but
à la 82e minute du milieu de terrain
sofiane boufhal le maroc dans le groupe
c remporte son premier match enfin noter
la victoire de la guinée contre le
malawi la guinée qui réussit aussi son
entrée dans la compétition le score un
but à zéro 1 but inscrit
ici à gars il ya un grand beau grand
bonheur des supporters écoutez le au
micro de notre correspondant à conakry
mali diakité
nous sommes très contents et très fiers
de notre équipe nationale et je pense
que cette première victoire va donner le
goût à tous les joueurs c'est à dire
pourquoi pas continuer jusqu'en finale
vers l'objectif c'est la coupe et
j'espère vraiment que c'est ce qui va
nous ramener la coupe à la maison
vraiment je souhaite que ça continue
comme ça ça se passe comme ça jusqu'en
finale aux us comme on ramène la coupe
chez nous ici pour une première fois et
le dernier match de la journée gabon
comores s'est soldée par la victoire du
gabon 1 but à 0 un but signé aaron
bouenza les panthères était privé de
pierre emerick aubameyang et de mario
les mines à positif au co vite 19
c'est la fin du journal de l'afrique
merci aux équipes en régie à célia
karassine à notre chef d'édition et
merci à vous de nous être fidèles restés
avec nous l'info continue sur france 24
[Musique]
et
du yémen à dire en toute l'actualité
politique économique culturelle et
sociale d'une région en mouvement
l'express orient le magazine du
moyen-orient présenté par meriem amellal
avoir sur france 24 et france 24 points
comme